it is the new year a lot of people make  resolutions for the new year so I  thought it might be fun to show you some  New Year's resolutions made by people  right here in our studio audience  for example his resolution let's take a  look there it is land the role of young  daddy in a barbecue commercial win the  award for Reno's most whimsical uber  driver find out if the Kardashian family  is accepting applications attend the  premiere of my first feature film  snowboarding Thor take the coming-of-age  roadtrip to lose my virginity write love  and friendship and discover that the  greatest journey is actually inside  myself move the bodies  I'm finally gonna tell my husband about  Ronaldo they're gonna tow Ronaldo about  Hans and I'm gonna tell Hans about  Melissa and finally remember to write  2017 of my checks instead of oh my god  Trump is president now we're all going  to die  [Applause]  you